work is over for the day and it's time
to relax
most of the cuban exiles in miami's
little havana district fled when the
communists took over in 1959
but their love of cuban music and
culture remains strong as does their
interest in events back home
many have their doubts about the
possible restoration of diplomatic
relations between washington and havana
the cuban government is very bad
controlling and controlling and again
controlling and the embassy is not big
change
will a new relationship between
washington and havana really make much
difference to the people of cuba
again there's skepticism
some of miami's cuban exiles say
president obama has betrayed them
obama have something for his legacy and
the cuban people who still have slavery
all i see is one failing president and a
dictator having a conversation
until my people are free can eat
can actually speak freely and live
i see nothing happening
but not everyone sees it that way
opinion polls of the two million cuban
exiles in the u.s suggest that support
for president obama's policy is growing
owns a cafe in miami and regularly
visits relatives in cuba
she has advice for people who oppose
restoring diplomatic relations get on a
plane
go to the island
talk to the cuban people and then come
back with empirical information
with the right information to decide the
fate of a of a country that you've not
visited in 15 years
before the communist revolution two and
a half million people a year travelled
between the u.s and cuba mostly by sea
entrepreneurs see investment potential
if restrictions are lifted
some businessmen have invested in
ferries hoping to start services as
early as this summer
brian hall invested in a high-speed boat
the fulfillment of a childhood dream
they may be operable
it's funny my grandmother she's a
vacation in cuba with her family and she
used to show us pictures and she used to
talk about how wonderful cuba was
and as a kid i always wanted to go to
cuba and
like what my grandmother did and and
because of embargo and everything else
hall's cuba cat service will offer a
three-hour journey for 170
he says it's a money spinner an exciting
turn of events after a lifetime of
building boats
the cube opening up for americans is a
lot like the
berlin wall falling
it's our here in north america and what
we see is um cuba cats will be able to
be the bridge to bring the families from
cuba to the families here in the u.s
they haven't been together in over 55
years they're gonna be able to come
together and it's a very exciting time
hall can only hope that the thor between
washington and havana continues